روى رجل أسترالي
القصة الرائعة لإنقاذه بعد أن
أمضى أكثر من شهرين في البحر،
انطلق تيم شاتوك وكلبه بيلا من
المكسيك في رحلة صيد في أوائل شهر
مايو متجهين إلى بولينيزيا الفرنسية، ولكن بعد أسابيع
من رحلتهم، تعرض طوفهم الصغير للتلف
في عاصفة تركتهم على غير
هدى، كان شاتوك في حالة صحية سيئة لكنه
تمكن من البقاء على قيد الحياة من خلال جمع
مياه الأمطار وتناول الأسماك النيئة، وأمضوا
أيامهم في الانتظار والأمل في الإنقاذ
الذي جاء بأعجوبة الأسبوع الماضي بفضل
طاقم سفينة التونة، هذا
ما كان لدى شاتوك  لأقول أنه بمجرد
عودته إلى الأرض،
انظر إلى القبطان
وهذه شركة الصيد التي أنقذت
حياتي، أعني ماذا تقول،
أنا ممتن للغاية
لأنني على قيد الحياة وأه
وأه لم أكن أعتقد أنني حقًا  أود أن
أوضح لك ذلك، شكرًا
جزيلاً لك،
وكان لشاتوك بعض الكلمات الرقيقة
لمحبوبته بيلا أيضًا،
وجدتني بيلا بيلا نوعًا ما في
وسط المكسيك، إنها مكسيكية، كما تعلم
أنها روح الوسط.
البلد ولم تسمح لي بالرحيل
إنها حيوان جميل وأنا
ممتن لأنها على قيد الحياة كما تعلم
أنها أكثر شجاعة
مني بكثير هذا أمر مؤكد